así es que tengo este rectángulo ahora
con una dos tres cuatro cinco seis siete
ocho nueve partes iguales vamos a
colocar aquí que tenemos nueve partes
iguales qué pasa si yo dibujo una de
estas partes iguales en morado vamos a
dibujar esta parte de aquí nada en medio
y si preguntara que representa esta
parte morada ustedes me pueden decir que
una de esas nueve partes está en color
morado de hecho podemos decir que esto
representa un noveno si nosotros
empezamos a dibujar más de estas partes
les digamos que ahora voy a dibujar este
y este
y este ya no tendré solo uno de esos
novenos están de acuerdo ahora tendré
otro noveno aquí otro noveno aquí y uno
más aquí si cada uno de estos novenos
los puedo representar como un noveno un
noveno y un noveno haré la suma de mis
novenos y tendré un noveno dos novenos
tres novenos cuatro novenos así es que
ya no tendré más un noveno sino ahora
tendré cuatro novenos
vamos a poner un poco más interesante
las cosas y nos vamos a este siguiente
rectángulo en este rectángulo vamos a
pensar tenemos dividido en uno dos tres
cuatro cinco partes iguales vamos a
llamarlo quintos
está dividido en cinco partes iguales
sigue dibujó una de estas partes iguales
y es tan tendré un quinto volvamos a
hacer lo que hicimos con el cuadrado
pasado un quinto
pero ahora se me ocurre que voy a
dibujar más de estas partes iguales y
dibujar está en amarillo y está en
amarillo
está en amarillo y está en amarillo
tendré entonces cinco de estas partes
dibujadas en amarillo y tú me puedes
decir oye pero si hago esto voy a tener
todo el rectángulo entero dibujado en
amarillo estamos de acuerdo y eso es
correcto si yo tengo cinco de estas
cinco posibles partes iguales voy a
tener un entero
podemos llamar que está dibujado en
amarillo todo el entero
lo ven
estaba dividido en cinco pero tengo esas
cinco partes en amarillo tengo un entero
vamos a hacer un poco de ejercicios y
les voy a mostrar estos dibujos abajo
para que ustedes ya no tenemos
adelantado pero esto es para que ustedes
puedan pausar el vídeo y una vez más
identifiquen en cada una de estas
figuras cuántas partes de ellas están
dibujadas en rojo o qué fracción de cada
uno de estos está dibujado en rojo
vamos a ir por cada una de estas figuras
para hacer nuestro ejercicio
tenemos este cuadrado que está dividido
en 1 2 3 4 5 6 partes iguales vamos a
colocar que tenemos esto dividido en
seis partes iguales cuántas de ellas
están en rojo vamos a contar una dos
tres cuatro
4 sextos de nuestro cuadrado están en
rojo o en rojo se representa 4 sextos
vamos ahora con este pay o círculo este
está dividido en una dos tres cuatro
cinco partes iguales
vamos a colocar cinco partes iguales
cuántas de ellas están en rojo
es 44 de las cinco partes o cuatro
quintos de este círculo está dibujado en
rojo vamos ahora con el triángulo en
esta ocasión este triángulo si está
dividido en partes iguales este
triángulo es igual a éste así es que
podemos decir que tenemos dos partes
iguales cuántas de ellas están dibujadas
en rojo pues una 2
y regresamos al rectángulo se acuerdan
tenemos dos de las dos posibles partes
iguales eso significa que tenemos el
entero
un entero dibujado en rojo dos de las
dos partes
esta última pieza sería muy tentador
decir que tenemos entonces cinco o seis
cuántas partes tenemos una dos tres
cuatro partes y que tres de ellas
estarían coloreadas en rojo
sin embargo mi duda es realmente está en
partes iguales este este lado rojo que
estoy marcando aquí es muchísimo más
grande que incluso los otros tres juntos
por lo tanto no podemos hablar de una
fracción vamos a tachar es de número
porque recuerda que para que podamos
hablar de fracciones necesitamos tener
nuestro entero dividido en partes
iguales y este no es el caso